Od teleskopů po velký hadronový urychlovač –
každý nový vědecký nástroj přepíše otázky,
které my jako vědci
a zvídavé mysli můžeme rozumně pokládat
– vysokovýkonné computing neboli HPC
se přidal do tohoto elitního seznamu v šedesátých letech – dnes
quantum počítače klepou na stejné dveře.
Vítejte, jmenuji se Conducive to Coffee
a jsem softwarový inženýr tady v IBM Quantum
– v tomto kurzu chceme naučit studenty
a profesionály, jak bude quantum computing brzy
spolupracovat s HPC infrastrukturami
a poskytovat výpočetní výkon
– dozvíš se, jak quantum
a klasické počítače komunikují a vyměňují data,
jak psát programy, které využívají oba typy hardwaru,
a jak tato integrace otevírá aplikace, které dnes neumíme vyřešit
– získáš praktické zkušenosti s reálným quantum hardwarem
a klasickými vysokovýkonnými výpočetními clustery,
budeš spouštět quantum joby vedle tradičních HPC pracovních zátěží
a naučíš se s jistotou interpretovat výsledky
a identifikovat místa, kde by quantum akcelerace
mohla výpočtům skutečně pomoci
a kde ne – a především pochopíš,
kam směřuje budoucnost počítačů
a cestovní mapu, která nás tam dovede – myslíme si,
že tento kurz je důležitý
i aktuální, a věříme,
že kombinování těchto technologií bude zásadní
pro dosažení výpočetní výhody
– to by mohlo mít dalekosáhlé dopady napříč odvětvími,
jako je chemie – kde by to mohlo umožnit
rychlejší vývoj léků a výzkum materiálů,
ve financích
pro chytřejší modely rizik
a detekci podvodů, v umělé inteligenci a strojovém učení
pro optimalizaci modelů – v tomto kurzu
se ponoříme hluboko do výpočetních zdrojů,
programovacích modelů a quantum algoritmů
– tak vítej a jdeme na to,
je toho hodně k probírání